Here's a neat little party trick that's guaranteed
to be a blast, and all you're gonna to need
is a bottle of soda.
The next time you're at a house party, there's
a good chance that someone will show up, with
some bottles of soda. Now if a bottle gets
shaken up, it's going to take awhile to open,
unless, or course, you don't mind making a
mess all over the place. But check this out.
When you master the soda ninja swipe, you'll
blast the cap off with incredible power, and
did you notice the soda isn't spilling over?
Instead, it creates a cool misty vapor that
gently flows out the top and over the sides.
The pressure in the bottles is enough to ricochet
the cap off the ceiling, and all the way across
the room. You can be sure you'll get some
attention, because everyone will be looking
around, to see what just exploded. If we mark
the bottle, and slowly unscrew the cap, you
can see it takes about one and a half rotations
to fully release. I measured that distance,
on a paper plate, and it's roughly 6" of travel,
or about 15.5 cm. Now the trick to an instant,
deCAPitaion, is to start with your middle
finger on the side of the cap, then roll it
down to your wrist in one swift, and fluid
motion. It might take a couple of tries to
get a feel for it, but just focus on swiping
the cap down to your wrist. Now the next time
you're at a party and you see someone pouring
themselves a drink, just hang tight until
the bottles, are half empty. Now make sure
the cap is on tight, and shake it like a maniac
to build up the pressure. Give it a few seconds
for the bubbles to settle back down again,
then slowly unscrew the cap, until you hear
a hiss. Back it off just a touch, and now
your bottle blaster, is charged and ready
to fire. Grab the bottle by the neck, line
up the cap, and unleash the power. Not only
does this look awesome, but the sudden bang
will make people jump. Now if you misjudge
the carbonation in the bottle, and it starts
foaming over, just slap your hand down over top,
and pretend nothing ever happened. Well now
you know, how to turn a house party refreshment,
into a soda bottle blaster, that will probably
leave your drinks a little flat, but will
definitely make you, the center of attention.
Well that's it for now. If you liked this
video, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com